- C'est dans ce CHSLD que la DPJ
des Laurentides a d'abord logé
des adolescentes début juin.
MARIE-ÈVE MEILLEUR, représ. nat.
de l'APTS, Laurentides
- Les jeunes filles sont
restées deux semaines au CHSLD,
et depuis le 15 juin, elles
résidentème étage
d'un hôtel à Blainville.
- Deux semaines plus tard,
la DPJ installe les adolescentes
dans cet hôtel de Blainville.
MYRIAM BRIAND, directrice, DPJ,
CISSS des Laurentides
- C'est une entrée indépendante,
notre unité de désengorgement
pour dix jeunes. Ils sont
pas en contact avec le reste
de la population... qui peuvent
avoir un hébergement à l'hôtel
Day's Inn.
- La nouvelle unité
d'hébergement aménagée à l'hôtel
a été baptisée la Transition.
- On a accès à des locaux
pour faire du gymnase. On est
en mesure de déployer l'ensemble
de l'offre de service avec
du personnel éduca
- Les centres existants
sont saturés parce que
les signalements sont
en hausse depuis un an.
- De 11 000 à 13 000 quelque
signalements. Donc, c'est
vraiment une augme
qui est très importante.
- Ça veut dire plus de jeunes
à héberger alors qu'on manque
de personnel. Et parce que
tement est plus
difficile dans le nord
des Laurentides, on déplace
les activités au sud
des Laurentides.
- Pour avoir le personnel
requis, c'est vers le sud. Bon,
bien entendu, Blainville c'est
bien situé, les gens veulent
travailler à cet endroit-là.
a été en mesure de
la staffer assez aisément.
- Pour régler le problème,
il faut un nouveau centre
jeunesse, qui selon le CISSS,
sera prêt en 2024.
CHRISTINE ST-PIERRE, députée
libérale, l'Acadie
- Voyons donc! Ils vivent sur
une autre planète! Le projet,
il était prêt. Le dossier
d'opportunités avait été fait,
on était rendus au dossier
d'affaires et on devait livrer
le projet en 2023. Pourquoi Poui
est-qu'ils n'ont pas lancé
le projet? C'est la question que
je leur pose et je leur dis :
ils ont été irresponsables.
- Le cabinet du ministre
responsable, Lionel Carmant,
convient du fait que
la situation n'est pas idéale,
mais précise que p
les ressources débordent,
il faut trouver des solutions,
même temporaires.
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mon